emile durkheim is the philosopher who
can best help us to understand why
capitalism makes us richer and yet
frequently more miserable he was born in
1858 in the little French town of apena
near the German border before he was 40
Durkheim was appointed to a powerful and
prestigious position as a professor at
the Sorbonne in Paris dark Heim lived
through the immense rapid transformation
of France from a largely traditional
agricultural society to an urban
industrial economy he could see that his
country was getting richer that
capitalism was extraordinarily
productive and in certain ways that it
was also liberating but what
particularly struck him and became the
focus of his entire scholarly career was
that the economic system was doing
something very peculiar to people's
minds it was quite literally driving
them to suicide in ever-increasing
numbers this was the immense insight
unveiled in durkheim's most important
work suicide
published in 1897 the book chronicled a
remarkable and tragic discovery that
suicide rates seemed to shoot up once a
nation has become industrialized and
consumer capitalism takes hold Durkheim
observed that the suicide rate in the
Britain of his day was double that of
Italy but in even richer and more
advanced Denmark it was four times
higher than in the UK Durkheim's focus
on suicide was intended to shed light on
a more general level of unhappiness and
despair in society suicide was the
horrific tip of the iceberg of mental
distress created by modern capitalism
across his career Durkheim tried to
explain why people had become so unhappy
in modern societies and he isolated five
crucial factors
in traditional societies people's
identities are closely tied to belonging
to a clan or a class few choices are
involved a person might be a baker a
Lutheran or married to their second
cousin without ever having made any self
conscious decisions for themselves they
can just step into a place created for
them by their family and the existing
fabric of society but under modern
capitalism it's the individual that now
begins to choose everything
what job to take what religion to follow
who to marry and where to belong if
things go well the individual takes all
the credit but if things go badly the
individual is in a crueler place than
ever before for its seemingly means that
there is no one else to blame but they
themselves failure becomes a terrible
judgment upon the individual this is the
particular burden of life in modern
capitalism
capitalism raises hopes everyone with
effort can become the boss advertising
Stokes ambition by showing us limitless
luxury that we could if we play our
cards right secure very soon the
opportunities are said to be enormous
but so too are the possibilities for
disappointment in modern capitalism envy
grows rife it's easy to become deeply
dissatisfied with one's lot not because
it's objectively awful but because of
tormenting thoughts about all that is
almost but not quite within reach the
cheery booster ish side of capitalism
attracted durkheim's particular
annoyance in his view modern societies
struggle to admit that life just is
often quite painful and sad our
tendencies to grief and sorrow and made
to look like signs of failure rather
than as should be the case a fair
response to the arduous facts of the
human condition
one of the complaints against
traditional societies strongly voiced in
romantic literature is that people need
more freedom rebellious types used to
complain that there were far too many
social norms norms telling you what to
wear what you're supposed to do on
Sunday afternoons what parts of an arm
it's respectable for a woman to reveal
capitalism following the earlier efforts
of romantic rebels has relentlessly
undermined social norms countries have
become more complex more anonymous and
more diverse people don't have so much
in common with one another anymore the
collective answers to even very
important questions like who should
marry or how you should bring up your
children have become weaker and less
specific there's a lot of reliance on
the phrase whatever works for you which
sounds friendly but it also means that
society doesn't much care what you do
and doesn't feel confident it has good
answers to the big questions of your
life in upbeat moments we like to think
of ourselves as fully up to the task of
reinventing life and working everything
out for ourselves but in reality as
Durkheim knew were often simply too
tired too busy too uncertain and then
there's nowhere to turn
Durkheim was himself an atheist but he
worried that religion had become
implausible just as its best sides its
communal side would have been most
useful to repair the fraying social
fabric
despite its factual errors in its
fantastical dimensions Durkheim
appreciated religion he knew that the
sense of community and consolation that
religion offer are highly important to
people capitalism has as yet offered
nothing to replace this with science
certainly doesn't offer the same
opportunities for powerful shared
experiences the periodic table might
well possess a transcendent beauty and
be a marvel of intellectual elegance but
it can't draw a society together around
it
in the 19th century it had looked at
certain moments as if the idea of the
nation might grow so powerful and
intense that it could take up the sense
of belonging and shared devotion that
had once been supplied by religion
admittedly there were some heroic
moments but they generally didn't work
out very well
family too seemed for a time to offer
the experience of belonging that people
seemed to need but today although we do
indeed invest hugely in our families
they're not as stable as we might hope
and by adulthood children are hardly
tied to their parents anymore they don't
expect to work alongside them they don't
expect their social circles to overlap
and they don't feel that their parents
honor is in their hands today neither
family nor the nation a well placed to
take up the task of giving us a larger
sense of belonging of giving us the
feeling that were part of something more
valuable than ourselves
emile durkheim was a master
diagnostician of our ills
he shows us that modern economies put
tremendous pressures on individuals and
leave them dangerously bereft of
authoritative guidance and communal
solace we are all Durkheim's heirs and
still have ahead of us the task that he
grappled with how we can create new ways
of belonging how we can take some of the
pressure off individuals and find a more
correct balance between freedom and
solidarity and how to generate
ideologies that will allow us not to be
so tough on ourselves for our failures
and our setbacks
you